here with reaction in the spin room Fox
News contributor kellyanne Conway and
Fox Business host Larry cudow good to
see you both all right headlines you run
away with anybody on that stage do a
better job than Joe Biden and KLA Harris
I think Donald Trump is a little bit of
a winner tonight because when his name
was invoked they kept saying he should
be here to defend his record he should
be here to debate he should be here to
Face the People why would you want him
there when he's going to eat into your
time and I think eat into some of their
some of their sound bites um I thought
it was a little flat today I thought
everybody had a good moment but moment
Sean will not overtake a front runner
leading by 40 points moments won't tell
the American people what you would do
differently it's got to be a big moment
we're in the rean library so we can say
this uh remember there was a lot of
questions about Reagan going into the
second debate with Mandel and he turns
to him and goes I will not allow my
opponent's Youth and inexperience become
an issue in this campaign even Mandel
started laughing it was game over at
that point there was nothing like that
tonight but look I think everybody did
well enough to make it to the next
debate in Miami which probably is their
goal the question is what are you doing
in during the 5 weeks in between the
debates these are important nights but
you got to get out there and mix it up
with the people and uh I I actually I
thought that the moderators are very
well prepared I you'd get extra credit
if you actually answered some of the
questions they came to play but they had
certain things they wanted to say and
they got it out they took on China which
is great there was a little bit more of
an economic plan on how to turn around
biomics and inflation young people can't
afford a yet people are in debt 40e High
mortgage interest rates 40-year high of
inflation people are suffering every day
I think there there was enough
connective tissue from these candidates
tonight that they can make a case I I
know a little bit more about your
struggles than maybe Joe Biden but um I
don't I think the polls aren't going to
move much no Larry yeah there were a lot
of little moments no big moments it's
hard to get a big moment um remember
Reagan said to Carter there he goes
again there will mean W oh God I mean
for 40 years that people have been using
that line so that's hard to get a big
moment I agree with kellyanne
um I wanted somebody to say as per
Reagan like I worked for Reagan long
time ago I come into the Reagan Library
we played all these Reagan Clips on my
show this night I wanted someone to say
as per Reagan that government is the
problem not the solution yeah I actually
played that clip of Reagan when he said
it the word was nine words I believe in
yes in the English Lang I'm here I'm
here from the government and I'm here to
help you that's right I I also wanted
someone to say that we need to get four
or 5% economic growth not 1% so we
should be slashing taxes across the
board we should be lowering marginal tax
rates the way John F Kennedy did the way
Ronald Reagan did the way Donald Trump
did I want to just someone to say that
tough stuff to get the economy moving
there were a lot of good points on the
economy they acted more like Republicans
this week than they did the last debate
did they make the sale on the economy
I'm not entirely sure but they punched
away at it to some extent I still don't
think Biden omic was buried today on
that stage I just don't think so I don't
think there were direct hits and I was
disappoint would you both agree with me
I felt there were a couple of people and
I'm I'm not going to sit here and be
insult a name name they just really
didn't have any business being on that
stage we all know they don't have a
chance and for them this is their moment
and and maybe the criteria needs to be a
little tighter going into any future
debate well there's going to come a time
Sean and Larry where you have to justify
being on the debate stage if you're
still Meed in single digits if you truly
want to get rid of Joe Biden and KLA
Harris people talk about Unity they say
the Democrats have Unity no the
Democrats have unanimity every single
Democrat votes exactly the same way
inflation reduction act not for the tax
cut and jobs act against Amy Coney
Barrett they all voted for Hakim Jeff's
15 ballots all 213 of them the point is
we can have Unity to try to get together
to defeat Joe Biden it's early in the
process but if time goes on and you just
making the debate stage and yet you're
mired in single digits in the early
States and Nationwide you have to ask
yourself how much can I sacrifice on
behalf of the team to get rid of Joe
Biden um we'll see what Gavin Newsome
has to say he'll probably bring a
message tonight that's a little bit
better than magga Mega magga Republican
deplorable irredeemable but I think if
you're a Democrat tonight you have to be
very worried that Joe Biden and K Harris
are not even being asked what they have
to say about this field people are going
let ask can I se can I just make a point
an exit question we have the governor uh
coming on in a minute here's my exit
question did anyone distinguish
themselves as a clear person you know
with Donald Trump's having such a
dominant leader in the polls as the one
person that could give him any run for
his money I don't think there was a
breakout breakout if that's what you're
asking no I don't think so L kellyan say
no not enough to overcome him in the
polls enough to survive so I think their
best argument is a war of attrition slow
and steady wins the race but no nobody
there made the case as to what they
would do differently or better than he
did they want to build a wall they want
to secure the Border they sounded a lot
like him uh and look I I give them
credit for taking on the big issues but
I I don't think that there was enough
Clarity and Sean I said to Larry earli
in the day I want to come out tonight
feeling a way I didn't feel after the
first debate which is each person has a
two or three point prescriptive plan to
fix this issue or that issue it forget
what we want to hear this is what the
American people want to hear and the
debate moderators were asking questions
on behalf of we the people that weren't
being answered with real quick Larry Tim
Scott I got to give Tim Scott a lot of
credit because he did this Riff on
blacks African-Americans somehow
surviving through slavery and then went
on to say that the Great Society of LBJ
and all the democratic presidents since
then have made the black situation worse
not better breaking up the black family
that was a power daming damaging black I
thought so he fac discrimination but
America is not a RAC I just have to give
him credit for that whether he wins
loses or draws that was something to
behold Afra to say that kind of thing
and the data the evidence shows that
Senator Tim Scott is absolutely right
the worst thing that happened to
minority groups and African-Americans in
particular in this country in the last
100 years was the Great Society and
they're leaving the Democratic party
Hispanics particularly I mean it's just
to both thank you Larry I thought it was
great being on your show earlier too
thank you I appreciate it uh all right
joining us now with more I see Ronda
sand is pulling up he'll be the first
guest uh is the host of the hit show The
Ingram angle the one and only Laura
Ingram now just a moment if I may the
single most question I'm asked is oh how
come we don't have the handoffs anymore
how come you and La how come Laura
doesn't you know poke at you every night
I know my football I left it I left it
in the other room darn it I was going to
throw it at the screen but they be mad
at me here if I break another camera um
Sean number one I miss you but you look
great you're doing a fantastic job but
let let me tell you dovetailing in your
previous conversation with kellyanne and
Larry I think after watching this T
tonight the debate I want to see before
your debate that you're going to host
between uh of course um DeSantis and
Nome is DeSantis and Nikki Haley because
for me at least tonight those two
emerged as the strongest advocates for
their brand of conservatism Nikki Haley
is a lot closer to the GOP establishment
the donor base uh on issues of regarding
Ukraine and and you know the immigration
system is broken all that kind of lingo
uh and then you have DeSantis who's much
more in the populist strain of Donald
Trump and probably the person if if
Trump ends up being the nominee likely
person to pick it pick up the torch
after Trump so a debate between those
two maybe without a moderator unless
it's you um I think would be fascinating
for the American people because all
those big issues debate Nikki Haley on
your I got it well a little bit but you
see what I'm saying I'm just you see no
but you see you see what I'm saying
about this those are that's it that's
the struggle inside the party the
populist part of the party is much
bigger it's 80 84% of the party versus
what 26% of the party uh or 16% of the
party depending on what polls you look
at so I think that would be interesting
I but I I agree I don't think anyone had
like a Sako movement I know V is coming
up he's a very smart guy um but he
seemed to be on the defensive a lot they
were all coming at him uh tonight and
and beram you know he seems very smart
but he has to he has to move on down the
road Chris Christie and Pence seem like
they're mostly motivated by their anger
toward Trump in running and so I think
both of them you know God bless them I
like both of them but that that's not
going anywhere so Haley and people want
to hear no I think DeSantis and and and
Nikki Haley that's the debate we want to
see if Donald Trump's not going to be on
the stage at
least well I'm going to ask the governor
right now uh considering you you pushed
that um anyway Laura we do miss you uh
but we're happy you're doing great at s
thanks so much for staying up and being
with us hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else